[Musica]
sveglia
macchina coda traffico scuola in ritardo
poi in salvo la palestra e allenamento
doccia cena studio poco eletto oggi le
giornate degli adulti dei giovani ma
anche dei bambini sono troppo spesso
dominati dalla velocità dalla frenesia
dalla voglio voler fare tutto e subito
sono state volontari nei riti haiti è un
paese poverissimo è uno negli ultimi nel
ranking mondiale quanto alle condizioni
dell'infanzia su 10 milioni e mezzo di
abitanti
al 56 per cento soffre di manutenzione e
ogni ora due bambini sotto i 5 anni
software muoiono di malnutrizione e
malattie curabili
un bambino su 2 non va a scuola
l'ottanta per cento alla popolazione
vive con meno di un dollaro al giorno e
il 70 per cento di una lavoro non ci
sono infrastrutture impianti fognari
pubblici strade ospedali o se ci sono
sono in condizioni disperate
oggigiorno è difficile che durante le
giornate lavorative universitarie
scolastiche si riesca se non in rari
momenti a trovare degli spazi in cui
pensare come sto vivendo come trascorso
la mia vita spazi durante i quali
fermarsi isolarsi riflette e di altri
aspetta come sto vivendo la mia
esistenza
credo che noi giovani spesso abbiamo
tanto in termini di beni materiali
relazioni opportunità ma siamo
insaziabili siamo continuamente alla
ricerca di qualcosa di più di quello che
abbiamo
io da haiti ho capito l'importanza del
frigorifero
sì perché quando tenti di camminare
nella baraccopoli di site soleil la
città del sole
circondato da centinaia di bambini
entusiasti di vederti che corrono
intorno a te riesce a vedere dove lo
ferma queste persone e ti accorgi che
volte non aveva il film di oliver non
hanno neanche i fornelli e se vuoi di
meglio neanche il frigo il divano alla
tele olivia stelle insomma non ci mette
molto a scoprire che non hanno nulla
eppure sono lì di fianco a te sorridenti
contenti che hanno voglia di giocare
insieme a te e probabilmente anno voglio
un po d'acqua e se chiedi loro come stai
la risposta è sempre la stessa stava bns
frase pronunciata con una dignità enorme
i bambini di haiti sono felici no non lo
sono ma in quei giorni insieme a noi lo
sono stati quei momenti per tutti quei
bambini che ci correvano dietro sono
stati diversi speciali una nota di
colore nel grigio delle masse
nauseabonde di rifiuti vivo il
volontariato come un'esperienza intima
profondamente personale penso al
contempo che sia giusto dare
testimonianza di ciò che mi ha
letteralmente trasformato voglio
condividere con voi la convinzione che
si diventa migliori aiutando gli altri
perché devi flesso avremo aiutato noi
stessi
ho vissuto questa realtà per due
settimane e ho capito l'importanza
dell'equilibrio
l'equilibrio è contrapporsi di opposti
che agendo si compensano luce e ombra
gioia e dolore
vita e morte troppo e niente
cerchiamo spasmodicamente di eliminare
il dolore della nostra vita convinti che
sia la cosa più ovvia da fare per
mantenere il nostro benessere e la
nostra felicità ma si sui social ad
esempio tendiamo a rappresentare il
mondo come bello facile felice un mondo
di eroi un mondo pieno di just energia
che un mondo pieno di sorrisi è un mondo
di vincenti massima perché siamo tutti i
paesi da altri e la verifica e dove va
in vacanza e poi nota l'hotel e scegli
le scarpe ci dimentichiamo ci
dimentichiamo di ascoltare e di
ascoltarci di sentire e diamo tanto
troppo per scontato
io da haiti ho capito che non puoi dare
nulla per scontato che la felicità non è
inclusa nel contratto e che soprattutto
devi dare un diverso
la vita cerco di spiegarmi un giorno mi
trovavo ad haiti all'ospedale nel
reparto di pediatria con mia mamma è
appunto una volta entrati in reparto una
giovane madre chiana si avvicina mia
madre e le chiede se le piacciono i
bambini e subito a mia madre le risponde
o wii wii gems enfants amo i bambini
allora la giovane madre tiana prende mia
mamma aveva il braccio e le dice allora
monfils e tampone sta nell'aver tua
allora prendi mio figlio e portalo via
contare pensate
una scelta quella di affidare il proprio
figlio a una sconosciuta ai più dolorose
scatti e strazianti per una madre e al
tempo stesso la più alta dimostrazione
di amore e il sacrificio
gioia e dolore amore e sofferenze non
sono forse questi ingredienti primi
della nostra vita
io non mi sono sentito mai così vivo
come ad haiti lì si è accesa mia una
fiamma una fiamma che mi fa vivere tutto
con più calore con più passione una
fiamma che solo dopo avermi fatto
bruciare a contatto con la violenza la
fame la povertà
avremo i destabilizzato aver fatto
quella e tutte le mie sicurezze mi ha
rigenerato ogni giorno ad haiti
si inizia la giornata con una messa che
la maggior parte delle volte è un
funerale e la consapevolezza che in un
attimo sta seppellendo un cadavere un
attimo dopo forse farei giocare altre
mille bambini
questa io chiamo vita
cercate la vostra fiamma grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no